The guy who directed "Underworld?"
A new writer, too?
Is the draw of Ana de Armas enough to bring
in dedicated "John Wick" fans, or will the
spinoff flop?
Here's why fans are worried.
When John Wick first arrived in theaters back
in 2014, the Keanu Reeves vehicle turned out
to be a breath of fresh air in a sea of middling
action thrillers.
The simple-but-effective revenge plot is emotionally
compelling enough that it allows audiences
to get behind Wick as he slaughters mobsters
with varying degrees of brutality.
Combined with killer direction from notable
stunt coordinators Chad Stahelski and David
Leitch, it's a rollicking movie that packs
a genuine punch.
"Yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
From there, the franchise flourished as John
Wick: Chapter 2 arrived in 2017, and John
Wick: Chapter 3 — Parabellum swiftly followed
in 2019.
The third film raked in just over $327 million
worldwide, so it's unsurprising that Lionsgate
quickly gave Stahelski the greenlight to work
on John Wick: Chapter 4, which is set for
release in 2023.
And, of course, there are also a few other
John Wick projects in the pipeline, including
a TV show revolving around the Continental
Hotel, and a spin-off movie known as Ballerina.
The feature film will follow one of the ballerina
assassins who briefly show up in Parabellum,
and it's set to star Knives Out and No Time
To Die alum Ana de Armas in the lead role.
Lionsgate recently confirmed that the movie
is supposed to start filming later this year,
but John Wick fans are already worried about
the spin-off.
Of course, the news that Ballerina is set
to start filming later this year obviously
has some fans excited about diving back into
the John Wick universe, but others are concerned
about who's attached to the project.
The film is directed by Len Wiseman, who's
best known for helming two of the Underworld
movies, as well as Live Free or Die Hard and
the 2012 remake of Total Recall.
The middling quality of these movies has fans
skeptical about what's ahead in the next chapter
of the Wickverse.
As one Reddit user recently posted:
"I like Underworld but those movies got worse
and worse [...] These guys on the same project
screams mindless action movie."
Meanwhile, another user voiced their concerns
about the involvement of John Wick: Chapter
3 and Army of the Dead writer Shay Hatten.
They said:
"Hatten and Wiseman films are not typically
films I get hyped about.
I liked John Wick 3, so if the fourth one
is solid Hatten may have found his niche.
But Hatten in combination with Wiseman gets
me worried."
However, it's entirely possible Wiseman has
changed his directing style since Underworld
— and a good example of his better work
is the live-action Swamp Thing series.
He served as a director for the first two
episodes as well as an executive producer
on the series, so it's entirely possible that
he could bring some interesting flair to Ballerina.
Regardless of how you feel about Wiseman's
involvement, the John Wick series has been
solid so far, so there are many more reasons
to be excited about Ballerina than there are
to worry.
First and foremost, Ana de Armas has firmly
established herself as one of the most exciting
actresses working today, and fans have come
out in full support of her casting.
As one Redditor says:
"I would watch this woman do her taxes."
But it's not just Redditors showing some love
toward de Armas.
On Twitter, one user wrote:
"Ana De Armas is starring in the John Wick
spin-off Ballerina.
That's all the information that I need about
the project.
I'm sold."
"It's like destiny that we were meant to meet."
No doubt part of that excitement came from
the actress' role in No Time to Die, in which
she played a gun-toting CIA agent.
Many people seem to see her casting as an
extension of that action-packed role; one,
for example, Tweeted:
"Hollywood: Remember the fun part of that
James Bond movie... alright how about we do
a whole movie about that."
It's important to note that, since it hasn't
even begun filming, we're not going to see
a Ballerina trailer for some time.
Clearly, there's still a lot left to be revealed
about this latest project, and for now, it
might just be best to keep an open mind.
After all, if any franchise can pull off a
pleasant surprise, it's John Wick.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.